[Music]
police officers in canada are trained as
problem solvers
so the more tools they carry in their
toolkit the more opportunities to
problem solve and sometimes it's about
building the relationship what's your
name
nick you know what
that was absolutely perfect what you
just did you stopped you looked both
ways because of that
i'm giving you a positive ticket my name
is ward klopham
i'm a 28 28-year veteran of the royal
canadian mounted police and i'm the
creator of the positive ticket program
nanaimo is a community of approximately
100 000 people it's a great place and
it's something that everybody should
come and see since the inception of the
program of positive ticketing we've
issued approximately 6 400 tickets to
youth i'm giving up positive tickets
okay do you know what a positive ticket
is the positive ticket program it's
about catching kids doing things right
rewarding them for good behavior it
could be for using a crosswalk good job
there you go
wearing a helmet when you're
skateboarding or riding your bike it
could be for doing your homework and for
many officers it's the icebreaker to
approach young people here i'm going to
give you a positive ticket here you go
niko thank you very much muhammad very
nice to meet you mohamed the positive
ticket idea really exemplifies the
canadian values we're recognized as
being really polite super polite so
that's for you
oh you're very welcome it's not about
the ticket it's all about the
relationship because you see what we
were finding was that the ticket for
many young people it was a trophy it was
a recognition that they were a good
person and they never had a police
officer let alone maybe a caring adult
tell them that they were worthy and that
there was something special about them
we had a whole pile of kids and they're
all pretty excited to see me
there's actually one kid in particular
she was pretty shy and pretty reserved
and dad was telling me he says you have
my daughter who's in kindergarten so
five years old
is scared to death of the police
and he says i've been trying to tell her
we're in canada now it's safe
the police are good i watched her across
the street she did exactly what i've
been trying to teach the kids
and so i gave her the positive ticket so
then she got a big smile
that's why i do this
since the program started in 2002 over a
million positive tickets have been given
out by police around the world
even if one percent of those million
tickets
turned into life-changing events for
young people that's a heck of a
difference
you